[Music]
when we first started working on the
book uh bruce and doug and i that became
difficult conversations the working
title was actually the 10 hardest things
to say and how to say them yeah
because we figured i don't know there's
probably like eight or ten or twelve
different types of difficult
conversations right and a conversation
with your boss would be different than a
conversation with your partner or your
spouse and that'd be different than a
conversation with your teenager
which is probably a volume unto itself
and so we'll just figure out what those
different types of conversations are
that implies conversations with your
teenager
fair enough
that is fair enough
so um
or conversations where if you're
listening to anything you say it's a
one-sided conversation
so we figure we'll we'll just figure out
what those different types of
conversations are and we'll have a
chapter about each and this is great
because people buy books with titles
like that
and so this is a fabulous plan
we quickly ran into a little bit of
trouble because we realized that we were
wrong
that actually it didn't matter who you
are talking to and it doesn't matter
what you're talking about
the same kinds of things show up in our
internal voice in any difficult
conversation meaning
the internal voice is what we're
thinking and feeling
but may not be saying to each other
and those fall into three categories
so the first is that
we're each thinking about
what's happening what has happened what
is happening right now and what should
happen so this is sort of our
story we tell about the facts
quote-unquote facts because it's really
an interpretation but
um and that includes what i'm right
about
who's right but usually what i'm right
about
whose fault it is that we're having this
problem
and also what your intentions or
motivations or character are like why
are you being so impossible why are you
being so stupid or difficult and those
are the three pieces of the story that
i'm telling about you but by the way
you're telling the same story about me
well a different story with the same
elements um you're focused on what
you're right about and
whose fault it is which is clearly
yours no you think it's mine
and why the other person's acting this
way so that's one level of the
conversation but there are two more
things going on beneath the surface the
second is that we're
by the time somebody becomes a difficult
conversation we're each usually
struggling with a whole host of feelings
of frustration betrayal confusion
guilt shame
anxiety
and
what do we do with those feelings often
we don't address them directly
we they simply infuse the conversation
that the energy that drives the
conversation and feelings get translated
into
blame and arguments and accusations
and if we don't talk about them often
we're not getting to the heart of what's
going on because by the time even in
business by the time becomes a difficult
conversation
typically we've got at least two
problems one is the surface problem like
you know is this timeline realistic
we're arguing about that
is this the right strategy um going
forward
who's right about that
but there's a second problem beneath
that which is how we each feel treated
by the other
which is that i've been telling you that
these timelines aren't realistic forever
and yet you keep blaming me
for missing them um because you're just
not willing to listen
and if we don't address how we each feel
treated
we might
resolve the surface problem but that
deeper problem is going to turn up in a
different form right next week or next
month
so
you've got
what happened conversation we call it in
the book the second is the feelings
conversation and then at the deepest
level is what we call the identity
conversation
and the idea here is that if a
conversation feels difficult chances are
there's something the situation suggests
about you that feels
troubling
or at stake or maybe
a little bit true
or maybe infuriatingly wrong but there's
it's not just that we're arguing about
money it's always about more than money
it's about whether i'm respected or
competent or a good person or worthy
of love even
and that's part of why these
conversations feel so high stakes
so the identity component
there's the what happened
component there's the feelings
conversation
as you mentioned then the identity is
how it affects how we view ourselves how
others view us or how
we view
others that's right and so here's a
simple example for people who have
trouble saying no
well that doesn't seem that hard just
say no more often you've probably gotten
that advice a million times right
but
it's not that you don't know how to say
the word no it's that chances are you
think of yourself as somebody who is
very loyal
or generous or all you know would never
abandon a friend in need well if that's
true then anytime someone asks you for
help
turning them down for that help is isn't
just
saying the word no it's doing something
that feels in conflict or intention with
who you
want to be in the world
and someone letting you know that you
let them down
will be a much harder conversation for
you than for someone who just doesn't
happen to have that identity story about
themselves right the guy in the office
next door has no trouble saying no to
everybody which of course why everybody
comes to you
because they know you'll say yes
so
that also helped us understand why is it
that some people have trouble with some
conversations and the same conversation
is easy for someone else
and it's partly because of whatever the
story is that you tell about yourself
and who you are trying to be
and once you have an understanding of
the three conversations which is in a
way it's kind of a meta anatomy of each
conversation right yeah it's like the
underlying structure of any difficult
conversation in the world
so once you have that x-ray vision and
you're able to
look at conversations through the lens
of these three conversations
does that then turn into a checklist or
an approach how do you translate that
into
thinking about
how to address
or prepare for a given conversation
yeah
so
um i think that they
that structure mostly serves as
landmarks
so i think that the way that we often
will well if you're like me
prepare quote-unquote prepare for a
difficult conversation is that we lie
awake worrying about it
and uh maybe we turn on the light and
jot down a few talking points right and
then we think about how they're going to
react and
then we think about our rebuttals right
to their reactions
and we're sort of charting a path like
i'm going to say this and then i know
they're going to say this so i'll
respond with this etc we're turning a
path through the woods to try to get to
the other side
and by the way
then we turn out the light and realize
yeah i don't know that this is worth
even bringing up right and now we're
back at the beginning
trying to decide whether it's even worth
trying
the problem though with the path
charting is number one it it sets you up
to do a lot of talking and very little
listening
um and the second is that
if you're wrong about anything the
minute that something surprising happens
you're knocked off your path
you're not following the script um and
so i think
i think the the reason that landmarks
understand that the underlying structure
helps is that it gives you some
landmarks so no matter where you get
dropped into the woods you can think oh
we're
whether we're saying it directly or not
we're wrestling over blame and who's
whose fault it is that we're in this
situation
so that's the first reason that
structure is helpful
the second reason it's helpful is that
the answer
isn't just to say everything you're
thinking the more transparent and
aligned you can be between your internal
voice and your external voice the better
however that doesn't mean you should
just
re-explain even louder why you're right
and why this is their fault you don't
just dump that sort of
toxic internal voice into the
conversation that's not going to help
instead the first negotiation is really
a negotiation with yourself
to move from being focused on what
i'm right about
and you're wrong about
to getting curious about why we see this
so differently so i don't have to
pretend i don't think i'm right i still
think i'm right
but given how obvious it is that i'm
right what the hell is going on with you
that you don't see it that's really
interesting
if i can get curious about that then it
actually shifts my purpose in the
conversation and the purpose of the
conversation isn't to hit you over the
head with how red i am it's instead to
understand why you see it so differently
and why we see it so differently so i
need to show my part two
you